beta-testing allows you to assure the
quality of your app by having real users
actually use it as a startup without a
quality assurance team it's great to
build a community of beta testers that
can give you the feedback you're looking
for let's hear from a mere savate about
what a beta testing community is and how
to create them Aamir's had a chance to
start some developer communities on
behalf of Google and is also the
instructor of Udacity product course
beta testing communities give you
insights you may miss about bugs in your
app or ways to improve your app that you
haven't thought of now choosing your
beta testing community members or
audience is really important there are a
few things you need to consider
they must be representative of the
actual users that will be using your app
when it launches for abarkment we should
actually find people who are dog owners
and who are willing to let their dogs go
stay with the sitter
they also have to be unbiased they can't
have predetermined notions of how they
feel about the app before experiencing
it and of course they must be willing to
give feedback and share their thoughts
it'll be no help to you if the beta
testers don't actually talk about their
experience the members of this community
should want to be a part of the
experience early on and really want to
be a part of the creation and
improvement of your app if your beta
testing you're gonna have the
opportunity to learn a lot of things
such as does your app even do what it
should do does your app crash or does it
have bugs is your app too slow what do
users think about your app how does your
up look or work on different types of
devices and so much more so you'll need
to think about how you want to interact
with your beta testing community because
it isn't only important for them to be
unbiased about the product you also need
to be unbiased so how should you gather
this information from your beta testing
community let's talk to Amir about that
so first of all I don't think you need
to ask questions you need to observe
behavior when one of the key with better
testing is that you get a lot of data
and rather than asking the questions you
see how people behave with with the app
and that's super important second if you
must ask questions you mean need to be
very very sure that these are unbiased
like asking things like is this a great
app will probably yield yes this is a
great app although it might not be a
great app right or
using it every day for sure who will
probably a bad question so try to not
prime the right answer your right answer
so ask your question in a very unbiased
way so here are a few things you should
remember when interacting with your beta
testing community observe behavior first
you don't always need to ask questions
you can just observe the behavior but
when you do be unbiased
don't ask leading questions to allow the
users to give room for honest responses
for more information on developing
questions for beta testing or surveys in
general check out the article in the
instructor notes another option is to
create open beta rather than a user
testing community google has a tool
called open beta you don't need to
create a community with this option to
run your test you'll use open beta when
you want any user with a link to your
app to be able to join your beta test
with just one click one of the major
advantages with open beta it allows you
to scale a large number of testers
however you can still limit the maximum
number of users you want to join your
beta test and finally don't forget you
need to collect data somehow as Amir
said beta testing without collecting
data is pointless you can setup a free
Google Analytics account to attach to
your app it'll be able to track user
behavior and provide you with reports on
data you're collecting so that you can
make data-driven decisions well dive
deeper into Google Analytics later on